un autre débat prend corps dans le monde
politique sur le respect des accords de
maastricht et l'institution de la
monnaie unique au 1er janvier 99
monsieur giscard d'estaing estime que la
situation économique doit amener un
assouplissement des critères retenus
pour monsieur de charette ministre des
affaires étrangères il faute
impérativement tenir ces critères pour
le ministre d'industrie monsieur borotra
entre l'emploi et les critères de
maastricht il dit je choisis l'emploi de
fait le point essentiel de ces fameux
accords de maastricht
eh bien c'est la limitation du déficit
national des états à 3% philippe sassier
1999 l'essence de la monnaie européenne
l'euro 2002 l'euro et dans nos poches
ces deux dates figurent dans le traité
de maastricht qui fixe les critères pour
y parvenir il y en a cinq essais cinq
critères permettront d'apprécier la
santé économique de chaque candidat le
critère le plus contraignant est
probablement celui du déficit budgétaire
le déficit du budget d'un pays ne peut
pas dépasser 3% du pib c'est à dire de
la richesse qu'elle produit chaque année
pour y arriver de solution couper dans
les dépenses ou augmenter les impôts
c'est trop difficile de suggestions
reculer la date de 1999 ou bien
assouplir les critères c'est tout le
débat politique qui est en train de se
développer en europe
il est